no
[Música]
apuesto que entre todos ustedes hay más
de una persona que ha recibido el
siguiente tipo de invitación a una boda
y más cuando te vuelves adulto joven y
que de repente todos se empiezan a casar
es una invitación en sobre blanco con el
nombre de la familia invitada membretado
la abres y de repente encuentras letras
doradas y lo primero que lee ese es el
nombre de los padrinos el nombre de los
papás de los novios y el nombre de los
novios obviamente en letras gigantes
doradas además de eso puede venir un
pedacito de papel en el que encuentras
el croquis del lugar en el que va a ser
el evento también te encuentras el
papelito en el que viene el número de
mesa de regalos y también la tienda
departamental donde los tienes que
comprar
pero cuando de repente él es hasta abajo
de la invitación en letras chiquitas
tres con dos puntos
etiqueta rigurosa en ese momento es
cuando te pones a pensar que estreses
code
como tengo que ir de etiqueta rigurosa
pero aunque es lo que te vas a poner
hola soy hecho herrera soy hidalguense y
soy diseñador de modas
después de recibir la invitación y de
que acabas de leer la frase 3 con
etiqueta rigurosa es cuando te calle el
20 de lo que te espera en la fiesta
y
pues básicamente esta frase incluye dos
palabras muy importantes
una de estas palabras
es código y la otra es etiqueta
les voy a dar una descripción fácil de
estas palabras código es el conjunto de
leyes y normas sobre una materia y
etiqueta
es el conjunto de formalidades y reglas
a seguir dentro de un evento
son conceptos que de repente uno no sabe
asimilar pero cuando los empiezas a
entender te das cuenta que han influido
de forma importante en la historia de la
humanidad
quiero explicárselo de forma más fácil o
sea como lo aterrizamos a nuestra
realidad de la vida
cuando tú te pones el traje te pones el
vestido te pones quizás también los
zapatos las joyas el reloj todo eso
básicamente empieza a ser el código y
este código lo que va a ser en conjunto
es generar un mensaje y el cual va a
transmitir la personalidad de cada
individuo
qué mensaje será pues dependerá de cada
persona pero lo que sí es que va a
resaltar muchísimo como les estoy
diciendo el ser de cada uno de nosotros
la etiqueta es el momento en el que en
realidad tú empiezas a usar todo esto
entonces puedes estar en la boda
tendrías que estar en un funeral y
obviamente tendrías que llevar algún
tipo de etiqueta o también podría ser
una entrega de premios o un discurso en
un escenario con letras grandes con
luces hablando frente a ustedes
en la historia de la humanidad ha habido
diferentes usos de etiquetas y códigos y
si pensáramos en estos códigos y en
estas etiquetas estaríamos claros que en
realidad fueron usadas y planeadas por
las altas jerarquías
[Música]
estas altas jerarquías no solo las
usaban ellos sino al mismo tiempo las
imponían en los de baja jerarquía hoy
por hoy para nosotros es importante que
de resaltar y hemos adoptado estos
códigos ciertas jerarquías
para darle estatus a nuestra vida
pero lo más importante es entender si
este estatus
es lo que en realidad importa
quizás tendría que importar más la
esencia profunda de nuestros eso y que
sería la esencia profunda de nuestro
acceso la verdad es que esta parte me
costó mucho trabajo poder la como
aterrizar porque al mismo tiempo cada
uno de nosotros podría tener una
percepción de esto pero podría ser
quizás tu forma de reír tu forma de dar
y de recibir el amor lo aguerrido y lo
fuerte que puede ser ante las
adversidades lo transparente que
realmente eres ante los demás cada uno
de nosotros sabe perfectamente qué tan
transparente es
pero en realidad la parte importante de
todo esto tiene que ver con que uno es
capaz de saber que sí y qué no
perdón
que que sí y que no forma parte de
nosotros y quiero contarles una
experiencia que viví que me hizo poder
empezar a analizar todo esto
un día tenía una junta muy importante en
ciudad de mexico
en la cual habría representantes de
diferentes marcas de diseñadores
mexicanos y justo a punto de llegar
me encontré a dos jóvenes que estaban
también por entrar al lugar donde yo
tenía que llegar a la junta y la verdad
es que me llamaron mucho la atención por
la personalidad que yo reflejaban con su
look
básicamente él llevaba un 'total black'
low cost iba vestido completamente de
negro pero con estoperoles piel un corte
de cabello asimétrico y ya llevaba un
vestido tornasol en tacones y unas gafas
gigantes
el encargado de la entrada al guardia
solo les pidió que se registraran una
libreta al mismo tiempo pues yo dije me
van a pedir exactamente lo mismo me voy
a registrar en la libreta y no pasa nada
cuando me tocó registrarme y pensé que
ya era básicamente todo aunado a que
obviamente le eche un ojo a ver quiénes
eran los chicos que habían entrado y vi
que obviamente ellos iban a la misma
junta que yo dije pues no pasa nada
entraré y en eso el guardia me dijo oye
este me tienes que dejar tu credencial
de elector y yo dije oye pero los otros
no lo pidieron y tengo una teoría
creo que el look que yo manejaba ese día
no era el look que estos chicos
manejaban que era muy atado al ambiente
de la moda yo básicamente iba con
playera blanca con pantalones negros y
además llevaba cargando unos porta
trajes que tenía que entregar
creo que eso puede influir un poco en la
perspectiva que el guardia tuvo hacia mí
y puede costar que a muchos les ha
pasado que de repente te tratan
diferente pero lo que me dejó claro ese
momento fue que
quizás podría parecer un repartidor y él
no lo entendía en ese momento así
y entonces lo que sucedió es que después
de eso mientras todo es todo eso pasaba
por mi cabeza yo le dije oiga pero y
porque ellos no les soy un poco prendido
de repente le dije oiga y porque a ellos
no les no les pidió la credencial de
lector
y le dije si ellos van a la misma junta
obvio porque yo ya me había fijado y me
dijo este hay joven discúlpeme este ley
es más soy diseñador de los que también
viene a la junta de la marca y me dijo
uno joven disculpe me pase y ya no pasa
nada no sé qué le dije no yo obviamente
te la dejo no tengo ningún problema con
dejarte la la verdad si me saca un poco
de onda tu actitud hacia la situación
esto es para explicarles que no busco
culpas y no busco dejar ni exhibir a
nadie
sino que más bien
el punto más importante de la situación
es que a veces como te ven te trata y lo
entiendo perfecto sin embargo también
hay un trasfondo detrás de cada persona
y esto va a reflejar en gran medida lo
que tú puedas lograr hacer como trabajo
otro ejemplo claro es cuando de repente
tocan en mi oficina y de repente abro la
puerta y la verdad es que yo sé yo
manejo un look en el que estoy de
playera y de jeans y le digo sí buenas
tardes este oiga se encuentra el
diseñador y yo sí soy yo y cuando veo la
cara de la gente así como de ustedes el
diseñador
y quizás aplica esa parte de yo no me
corto el cabello con alguien que no
considere que tenga padre el cabello no
es como un poco complicado sin embargo
también sé que el resultado mi trabajo
es el que habla y es básicamente lo que
me ha enfocado
[Música]
es que desarrolle muchas ideas y de
repente creo que se me fueron al cielo
y ahí es cuando te das cuenta que el
cliché de lo que todo el mundo tiene en
la cabeza sobre un diseñador tiene
espera una imagen estrafalaria
obviamente la gente podría esperar
quizás que sea alguien con plumas en la
cabeza y un sombrero o algo así y la
verdad es que es cuando considero que no
es necesario tener estas estos clichés
la influencia de la moda hoy por hoy
está en nuestras vidas
yo como diseñador dedicado al mundo de
la moda yo sé cómo tengo que lucir
quizás pensándolo desde la desde la
primera perspectiva sin embargo que la
moda hoy influye día con día y ahora
quien dice que no sigue la moda y la
realidad es que todos las seguimos
porque al final la moda hoy cree estilos
de vida y estos estilos de vida están
basados en cosas que ni siquiera
imaginamos un día tuve la oportunidad en
un trabajo de poder usar una plataforma
que está enfocada a la predicción de
tendencias y cuando lo pude usar porque
es un sistema es una plataforma mundial
la verdad es que fue algo que me dio
mucho miedo porque
te entregan desde balances económicos de
ciertas empresas para que tú puedas
darte cuenta del nivel que se puede
lograr también te entregan reportes
sociológicos que son a macizo pero que
hay gente que no pensaría que la
sociología está involucrada con la moda
pero cuando lees es dudar tipo de
artículos o cuando de repente te dan la
idea perfecta de cómo tienes que hacer y
generar cada experiencia para un cliente
es cuando te das cuenta de que la
predicción de todo esto realmente está
influyendo en nuestras vidas hoy
decidimos a través de las influencias y
la moda sin pensarlo tan literal como
pintar nuestra casa que toallas usar que
vice comprar que comida y qué plato usar
también es más y comemos mucha comida o
buscamos comer comida instagram e hable
para estarle tomando fotos todo el
tiempo entonces cuando alguien me dice
que la moda no es parte de su vida y hay
una frase que dice
este todos se tienen que vestir no la
recuerdo exactamente pero el tema es
todos buscamos vestirnos pero quizás no
todos buscamos seguir la moda yo la
verdad es que tengo un poco de duda con
eso porque yo creo que al final
queriendo no la influencia de la moda
está presente en todo esto quiero
retomar un poco el tema de la esencia
profunda del ser
la verdad es que como la palabra lo dice
profundo la masa es que si es así como
un término muy profundo pero esto es muy
claro en qué
todos estos etiquetas y códigos que hoy
usamos para cualquier situación en
nuestra vida en realidad si van a
exponer nuestra personalidad
pero al final
pero al final la verdad
perdón pero estoy súper nervioso no
saben cómo pensé que esto iba a ser más
fácil de lo que pensaría este bar
lo de la esencia del ser ya perdonen es
que te estoy pensando en todo lo que les
quiero decir quiero retomar el tema de
la esencia del ser porque al final poder
adornar nuestro cuerpo poder llevar lo
que consideremos nuestro estilo de vida
si estará basado en las tendencias y en
todo lo que creemos pero al final
nuestra decisión será la que guiará lo
que realmente queremos consumir y ahí es
donde tenemos que aprender a discernir
entre lo que si queremos usar y lo que
no queremos usar poder pertenecer a
través de lo que usemos sobre lo que no
usemos convertir a nuestra realidad en
un mensaje muy claro y ese mensaje claro
siempre será un mensaje de éxito el
éxito para mí y creo que para todos
ustedes es como la búsqueda de todo lo
que queremos en la vida pero el éxito al
final del tiempo en realidad tendría que
ser por lo estar basado en lo que más
vale
y yo como diseñador me he topado con
situaciones que esperaría que fueran
fáciles para mí surfear dentro del mundo
de la moda sin embargo aunque es un
nuevo una un ambiente complejo
he intentado yo mantenerme en el mejor
de esto que he podido adquirir para mi
vida el resto de la fidelidad por eso es
que está charla se llama así
la fidelidad en ti mismo puede permitir
que aunque la moda puede tenerlos
cautivados eternamente podamos ser uno
mismo y podernos mantener en la línea de
nuestro éxito y de lo que hay dentro de
nosotros que es la esencia del ser único
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]